the Joe Rogan experience I'm entirely
convinced that we're going to in inside
of a hundred years live in a world where
all of your thoughts really are
documented and there's there's they have
access to them the same way no one in
their wildest dreams conceived of
photographs 400 years ago and 400 years
from now we're gonna have the ability to
record record thoughts and ideas and
they're gonna be able to read the
contents of each other's minds right
that could be well maybe that maybe we
need some regulation there maybe or
maybe we just have to accept the fact
that most of what goes wrong in the
world goes wrong because people can
think the secret sneaky fucked-up
thoughts and when we those no longer
exist anymore maybe we'll clean out
human behavior there was an outer limits
episode about that in the 1950s might
have been the other one pilot zone
Twilight Zone where this guy all of a
sudden is able to read the minds of
other people and he's at work and he's
you know listening all these
conversations and you know all this fun
stuff but then this is one guy who's
really dark like he's kind of he's gonna
come in and blow everybody away and so
you know sort of climax is where he you
know he comes in and tells the boss
everybody and they you know they go in
there and it turns out the guy well I
was never gonna do that I was just angry
and I was just thinking that you know so
that's like a minority former thing you
know you could have these thoughts right
we know from research that this is David
buses research on he wrote a book on
murders the murder next door it's called
and so he did the research on asking
subjects have you ever thought about
killing somebody you didn't like and
turns out like eighty percent of guys
and 67 percent of women have had
homicidal fantasies in their life now
99.9 percent of us never act on our
homicidal fantasies but we get mad
enough we can imagine and he's got the
narrative accounts because he also asked
him tell me what you would do and oh my
god they're just incredible to read like
I would break every bone in his body and
then I would pull out his fingernails
and then I would they go on here you're
like holy [ __ ] but that's just fantasies
fantasy yes some people have suicidal
fantasies yeah there's people there are
fantasies of jumping
of a giant building right now I mean but
day but most don't act on and most don't
act on it and there's people that just
have these thoughts and they think I'm
they look at the edge and they go I
could just jump off right now and end
this whole thing but I won't and
should be punished them no of course the
Minority Report scenario it's like okay
we found out for that this guy's
thinking about robbing the bank so he
had a fantasy about it he's not gonna do
it I've thought about doing that this is
really fleeting I was like what would I
do if I had to rob this bank I mean I've
never actually considered robbing a bank
but I thought okay I'm at the bank what
do I just decided to pull out a gun and
everybody at the floor where's the
cameras where's the security guard you
know like you've seen so many movies
it's if you're bored you know but today
that's another thing people are rarely
bored because when they are they just
pull out their phone and stare at
pictures of others butts right it's it's
like you know you just pull out Facebook
or Instagram and no longer bored you
know when I was in my religious phase in
in college I asked before I went to
Pepperdine which is a religious clubs at
Glendale college just keep ige of the
way and my philosophy professor was an
atheist and I was an evangelical so I'm
telling them about Jesus and the whole
thing in the afterlife and he says any
want to know are there golf courses and
tennis courts in heaven I gotta have
something to do I'd be bored I thought I
have no idea and then I also quote from
Julia Sweeney is letting go of God
monologue she opens this monologue you
know Julia from Saturday yeah with the
Mormon boys coming by her house in
Hollywood and there pitching their story
like okay come on in pitch me your story
like it's a Hollywood you know movie
script you know what do you got so they
tell her the whole thought it's gonna be
great you know the blind shall see again
the theft she'll hear again and your
body will be whole again and so she says
well let's see
I had uterine cancer so I had my uterus
taken out do I get my uterus back when I
go to heaven they said yeah I don't want
it back this is what if you had a nose
job and you liked it do I have to get my
old nose back
right as I open this little funny story
because it gets to the problem of
identity who are you so if you're
resurrected with Jesus the early earlier
Christian cult sex before Descartes
introduced dualism they believe that you
are when you're resurrected at the you
know after your death you are physically
there in heaven physically and your soul
the whole thing it's just one thing so
the question is well how old are you
when you're there you know so you're
brought up and there you are sitting
next to Jesus and God and whatever you
know so they okay thirty thirty seems
like a good year it's your Jesus was
crucified okay thirty like but wait a
minute I'm 63 now so what happens all
the memories of my life for the last 33
years oh no you get all those memories
okay but the memory the memory of my
being thirty now is different from the
memory I had when I was fifty of being
thirty and forty being thirty and even
when I was in my 30s being thirty you
know that the memories are always
changing and edited in and forgotten or
modified particularly based on life
experiences that happen afterwards so in
your 20s you go to this college you
marry this person you take this job or
whatever you don't really know what the
impact of those decisions are until much
later in life which is why I'm always
think it's particulars for people to
write memoirs in their 20s or 30s
because they're celebrities you have no
idea what those things actually mean
until much later so this is the problem
of who you are so first of all we we
already know that none of your body is
the same material it was say a decade
ago your cells are all recycled the
molecules and atoms are gone there's new
ones that replace it's the pattern it's
the pattern of information that
represents you Joe Rogan this is what
you look like these are your memories so
somehow that this has to be copied so in
the Ray Kurzweil scenario of the
singularity we're going to upload the
mind they're gonna copy your connectome
all your memories in your synapses
okay so right away there's the problem
of which memories well all of them no
there are no fixed set of memories that
are you your memories are always
changing so the moment you take a
snapshot of it that's just a fixed point
that's not you really you are this whole
you know long continuum that's always
kind of flexible
changing so there's that and then
there's the problem with the up mind
uploading scenario is there's two kinds
of cells there's the memory self memsaab
of all your memories and then there's
the point of view self the POV self so
when you go to sleep tonight you wake up
tomorrow you're still looking at the
world through your eyes and there's a
continuity a point of view from one day
to the next
same thing with general anesthesia so
like in the Johnny Depp movie
transcendence where he's poisoned by
these terrorists and he's died and he's
got like a week to go he copies his mind
connectome equivalent of the genome and
puts it in a computer and then he dies
and they turned the computer on and he's
in the computer looking out through the
little camera I don't see how this could
happen that is if we copied you your
connectome everything all your memories
so we had a Joe Rogan number two copy
ready to go but instead of you dying
let's say we had a sophisticated fMRI
brain scan machine slid you into it
copied your connectome uploaded it into
the cloud or whatever and you're and
then we slide you back out and you're
standing there you you're still looking
at the world through your eyes that's
just Joe Rogan number two a copy and no
more do you look at that then a twin
looks at its sibling and says well there
I am no no you're still standing there
go know that I'm here that's just a copy
of me and so this to me seems a central
problem with the mind uploading scenario
it's just a copy did you see the thing
in National Geographic today about the
cloned monkeys no they've they've
managed to actually clone monkeys no and
yeah Jamie I uh I tweeted it earlier
today it's crazy and well we're
speculating that if they can do that to
monkeys they're going to be able to be
able to hear that - Hugh yes but again
so who is right who is that there's a
Michael Shermer is it your twin I mean
like when you meet twins it's very weird
like ice date a girl was a twin she had
a sister looked exactly like her but
like a little aw just as something just
a feel like oh you're not her super
super confusing so they weren't the same
person but they pretty much were yeah
here's the here's the article scroll up
there clone monkeys created in the lab
now what yeah okay
well so you're making copies yeah so
it's a copy but it's not the same person
because none of your own individual life
experience is the moment you and your
copy start diverging away and leading
different lives or you have different
memories
[Applause]